some of the biggest names in british
music have written to the culture
secretary
warning him that hundreds of thousands
of jobs in the live music industry
are at risk 1500 artists say the
government needs to act
to save what they call a world's leading
business
and we can speak to one of those artists
who signed the letter the musician
katie tunstall katie really good to see
you this morning thanks for joining us
all the way uh from over there in l.a um
tell us why did you hi thanks very much
tell us why did you sign up
to the letter well i mean sure i'm in la
now but
i owe a huge debt to those
that entire structure of grassroots
venues back in the uk
as do almost all the artists that come
out of britain
and i was put into perspective for me
today that we
per capita we are the second biggest
live ticket market in the world
for live music the live music scene is
an enormous
uh success story in the in the in
britain for the last
two decades it's bringing in four and a
half billion a year
employing over 200 000 people
and we're basically in a situation where
sport is being given that support but
unfortunately the live music sector is
not
why do you think that might be i don't
think oliver dowden is particularly a
footballer and this is nothing certainly
not necessarily
much of a musician um but why do you
think the preferential treatment
i think there's just a bit of a
historical attitude towards music that
it kind of gets on with itself
you know people form bands and garages
people play pubs and clubs and then
suddenly
magically they turn into headliners at
glastonbury but of course that's not how
it works it takes a lot of work
takes a lot of energy and it does take a
lot of money and
it's not just the musicians on stage
it's this
entire structure of people
working who are by the way mostly
freelancers so aren't
eligible for much of the government
support a lot of them
um and unfortunately because of that
freelance nature of music industry
if they can't get any support they will
get jobs elsewhere
so even if we do go back to playing
they won't necessarily be necessarily be
a workforce
force left to actually support those
gigs but as an ambassador of the music
venue trust
i am also privy to the fact that 97
percent of grassroots venues
will not be able to stay open with any
kind of social
distancing and and the only way of
avoiding that
is some government assistance i wonder
whether part of the problem
might well be that for for many people
perhaps those who are not regular
concert
gig goers they tend to think of the o2
the manchester arena these
massive venues that exist but actually
fundamentally
what is the backbone of the british
music industry as you've already
mentioned
are those smaller places that get you
out there in front of the public and get
you the experience
the launch pads and their their labors
of love
these venues you know they're constantly
up against rising business taxes they're
constantly
up against developers trying to buy the
properties and turn them into flats
and they're just to be honest a lot of
them are hanging on by the skin of their
teeth
anyway regardless of the pandemic and
and what has
you know happened because of that so
it's really it's crunch time i've heard
people talking about this in terms of
live music as an extinction level event
and it sounds dramatic
it really is this is a really dramatic
uh potential future for live music
and really we've got to look at
um at how important
live music and the experience of live
music
is to our country because
it's really in peril right now
um how is lockdown being then for for a
musician
like yourself i mean have you been able
to collaborate with people we've seen
plenty of video conference bands coming
together i mean has that been your
experience
i found it pretty hard to be creative
during this time i managed to do a
charity song about washing your hands
for water aid and more childhood
that was great and i wrote a 20-second
chorus which
is the perfect hand wash so i'm very
proud of that
but you know all of the videos you see
it's impossible to play in real time so
we're having to kind of cheat a little
bit there and it's
it's really tough and it's very
isolating for everyone not just for
musicians obviously
but music i did a fantastic panel today
with harvey hancock i can't i still
can't believe i was
i was talking to harvey hancock but he
he really
said what i feel about music is that
music
is a healing force music is transcendent
of language it can
it's such a galvanizer it's such a hope
giver
and it's needed more than ever right now
and you know the streaming income is
just a mess at the moment for musicians
they're not making any money from that
so really we need
to and it's not a criticism of
government at all it's simply we
have to ask them to help
us in this situation of course i'm very
lucky i've got a
couple of hits that make my money but
these new artists are just completely
done for and we're looking at
an entire generation of artists
potentially having to walk away from
doing it at all because they just need
to go and
get work elsewhere sing it sister ah
katie tunstall many thanks for joining
us in the programme really lovely
to talk to you